postscript alter nach
david nein nein
es geht so herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde ende tiger mother und wir spielen
heute ganz alleine einfach mal schillig
und keine roboter in folge sondern
einfach mal ganz entspannt
immer wieder ändert sich hat mir nämlich
gedacht bzw
mir ist der einfall gekommen es gibt
bestimmt ein paar leute die jetzt nicht
die ganze zeit nur rote top ten sehen
wollen wenn ich ende ganz spiele und ich
habe ja letzten endes folgen nur als
rote top ten gebracht sondern einfach
mal lust darauf haben einfach mal wieder
so eine gezielte ende gab es aber so wie
es früher war
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht mach'
mal schnell mal wir spielen das känguru
kit auf diesem wunderschönen biologen
hier haben jetzt schon zehn gold aber
sonst nichts
es ist nicht so dolle und ist gerade
echt voll ihr es geht richtig richtig
voll war
ja ich bin gerade in der klausurphase
leute das heißt ich schreibe meine prüft
genoni und dementsprechend kam jetzt die
letzten drei tage kein video das ist
schließlich nicht daran dass ich dass
ich keinen bock hat oder nicht einfach
wirklich keine zeit und es ist mega
arbeitsintensiv guckst du nicht stellt
kann man sich machen also was sie gerade
machen muss ist echt richtig krass
richtig viel zu tun und da finde ich
leider keine zeit neuen video zu machen
und da ich glaube ihr könnt das
verstehen sagt er sonst immer super cool
bedeuten sachen und ja jetzt habe ich
immer gedacht heute mal wieder eine
gestern habe ich die letzte person
geschrieben und habe jetzt mal kurz
pause und hab ich gedacht kann es mal
wieder ein video machen und man kommt
mit dem schrecken können keine feier von
den getroffenen krass das ist schon echt
ok den arm erwischt
der ist auch gerade jetzt wir waren
gerade irgendwann richtig sie richtig
seltsamen channel auf dem teamspeak
warum bin ich über intimste wenn ich
alleine aufnehme das weiß kein mensch
studie publik
lass dich töten ok
nicht so bock darauf okay dann
vielleicht die das wort book ja das
kommt sehr schön
ok gewonnen denn krims krams sack wenn
wir richtig viel spaß aber ich warte bis
zum nächsten switch bevor wir uns da
hier gut eindecken so gesittet okay das
war heute ganz mit dem bogen
bevor ich in den kampf gehen aber das
hat dann immer den nachteil dass jetzt
schon wissen dass da gleich einer kommt
und wenn man die ja gut erwischt sonst
kann man einfach hier paaren pro bahn
und die einfach komplett weg wäsche
trick paar nice ok hätte ich nicht
gebraucht die idee an mich richtige
horst aber sowieso noch genug stoff für
eine leggins noch genug deswegen macht
es überhaupt keinen unterschied
ok jetzt immer wieder fully equipped und
können loslegen ja leute was ich noch
unbedingt sagen wollte die klausuren
phase wird auch irgendwann ein ende
haben und dann wenn die zu ende ist dann
kann ich wieder nach hause zu meiner
familie leer
und dann wird es richtig abgehen dann
werde ich nämlich auch mal wirklich
regelmäßig live streams bringen und zwar
na ja ich würde sagen ich hab mir dann
ich habe richtig viel zeit
natürlich sagen so locker easy locker
easy x 34 live streams in der woche um
das wird glaube ich richtig tun nämlich
richtig lust drauf zu stream ich mag
spielen so sehr aber ich habe hier unten
weder den rechner noch die leitung dafür
leider obwohl ich theoretischen 100 km
habt ihr es so unfassbar schlecht es tut
richtig weh seiner leitung zu haben das
bereitet mir richtig schmerzen hat mache
ich die schauer und nicht so toll
ich weiß nicht wer es kennt also ich bin
hier
ich werde euch einen anbieter nennen
oder scheiß drauf kabel bw einfach auf
jeden fall horst eckel
okay okay es gibt werden intercell hat
irgendwie blog ist er auch so
david nein nein er hat es sich für ihn
bekommen
nein das gibt es doch nicht
jetzt stört es nicht verdient ihr
pinkelt nicht dein zeug
ein kollege so wird nicht gespielt sie
keine anrufe 28 der hat wahrscheinlich
ja da wird wohl das dings größer als bei
1 mal hinten
wir wollen nämlich schauen ob da
registiert aufgenommen hat der war glaub
ich gerade dabei und er hat es noch
nicht aufgenommen jetzt coco go go go go
go go go gib mir die sachen wie viel
zeug was es sehr sehr sehr gut da können
wir jetzt noch schnell eine machen
wisst ihr was ich meine
genau wie ihr moment heimischen die
abruzzen
das war wohl eine andere keine ahnung
manchmal passt ihn selbst aber sachen im
kopf na gut auf jeden fall kümmert jetzt
den kolleginnen dahinter mal vornehmen
komme es auch vor knöpfen und mal
schauen dass wir diese runde dieses
kleine brötchen
ich bin ich habe es echt gott ich hab so
verdeckt ich habe einfach nicht geteilt
dass ich känguru ist die känguru platz
also ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht ob
ich dir jetzt ob ich die fähigkeit
benutzt aber ich glaube ich gar nicht
benutzt jetzt in der rolle
zumindest nicht in genf als alter kann
man so verteilt sein kann man so
verteilt sein
naja egal ob verteilt oder nicht wir
fahren jetzt fulda und das sage ich eine
richtig geile runter muss ich sagen
also wenn wir die nicht gewinnen müssen
wir schon eine menge pech würde ich mal
sagen du wirst jetzt stimmt die britin
bist du steht bubi ach alles nicht
stimmt die bundesschulden ellbogens geld
das war selbst am irgendwie seltsam
position
ich musste kurz wieder leise sein mal
schnaudt hatten denn die so unendlich
verlieren lauf gar nicht so gut stimmt
ja ok
da hat er uns doch noch gut schaden
gemacht dafür kriegt auf jeden fall ngg
in die indiana games kaster und den
schicken können nicht mehr es sind acht
minuten da können wir theoretisch jetzt
schluss machen ist schon relativ spät
wir haben jetzt moment für 15 uhr 41 das
heißt es muss jetzt wirklich rasend
schnell genannt dass wir noch
rechtzeitig hoch kommt und ich würde
sagen wenn ihr bock auf diese live
streams habt im sommer dann lass ein
like da ich will mal schauen ob wir mal
wieder so einen live-chat schaffen
schafft ihr 106 dieses video rein zu
ballern für dieses dings im sommer ihr
wisst bescheid für die ganze live
streams und die runde an sich war glaube
ich auf einen leitwert will ich sagen
einfach mal schwer und ansonsten würde
ich sagen
check niemand rp die beschreibung ab wie
immer dabei wenn ich alleine spiele der
niemann lp und dann würde ich sagen
haut rein habt einen schönen tag und
schuh